So, I've gone ahead and
added the .error method to the end of the getJSON method.
Chaining in this case refers to just simply attaching another method to
the end of one method.
So, we'll run .error if something goes wrong with anything that happens here.
In which case, .error runs an anonymous function that takes in e,
the error itself.
But in this case we don't do anything with e.
We simply change the text of the New York Times header element to
New York Times Articles Could Not Be Loaded.
And let's go ahead and see if this worked.
To test this, I went ahead and
messed up the URL, so let's go ahead and hit Submit.
And, we can see that despite the fact that we got Rockefeller Center in
the background, the New York Times articles could not be loaded.
This is a good way to make sure that even if the page doesn't work the way you
think it should, it doesn't completely ruin your user's experiences.